hey everybody how's it going had a good
lunch so nice sandwiches good coffee
good drinks all set to go for another
couple of hours of awesome Google cloud
technology so today in my session I'm
going to talk to you about building a
custom chat bot with API to the ion
cloud functions so who has ever built a
chat bot before ok who is planning to
build one in the next let's say 12
months ah obviously chat bots are a
little bit the hype right now so I'm
very glad that we had this big room to
go through it with with us together so
my name is McCallum - I'm a customer
engineer at Google based on Google
answer them and in this session we will
cover three things the first one is the
the basic building blocks of building a
chat BOTS the second one is a
demonstration of how these building
blocks actually work so this will be the
exciting part for me and hopefully also
together with you we can have some
working prototype by the end of this
session and then last but not least Tim
Daniels from ing will share what they
have built the last six months and also
the lessons learned along the way but
first maybe it's a good idea to take a
step back so the people who were in the
hero keynote this morning have already
heard our mission statement to organize
the world's information and make it
universally accessible and useful and if
you think about it this is also what
we're doing for Google clouds so we're
organizing your business information and
make the information you want to share
universally accessible and useful for
your stakeholders your customers your
partners and also your employees what's
maybe interesting about that is that
we've developed a lot of tools for
organizing information we have covered
big data we're looking into machine
learning but the part I want to focus on
is making it universally accessible this
not only means making it accessible
across the globe with low latency and
high availability but it is also
mentioning how people actually interact
with your information and that's where
we see a lot of change happening the
last few years
so traditionally people had to adjust to
technology to cope with it so people
have to learn to work with a keyboard
people had to work to learn to work with
a mouse stuff like that you can even go
back to the typewriter versus where
people also had to learn to work with
with typing and not writing or speaking
the natural way of people to communicate
obviously at the end of 2000 around 2008
or was this a smartphone with this giant
touchscreen which enabled you to use
gestures to actually use your fingers
you know these tools you use every day
to interact with the world around you to
also get something back from technology
now the third wave we are seeing and
this evolution is the AI first so that
we really can talk to the computer like
we do so the humans don't have to adjust
the technology but technology can adjust
the humans so we can just speak like we
normally do we can just write like we're
no normal right sentence to get
something back from technology and this
is obviously where the chat BOTS fit in
through the advancement and machine
learning and compute we are now at a
stage where we are very confident and
what the technology can do and that's
also why you see a lot of activity
around this topic so let's make it a
little bit more concrete and look at the
basic architecture this architecture is
both for voice chat BOTS so you speak to
them like the Amazon Alexa Microsoft
Cortana or of course the Google home but
can also be used for text books so if
you have it integrated on your website
or in your mobile application you can
use the same basic architecture so the
first one is the user interface then we
have the conversational agent platform
and to fill it up we have the
fulfillment side so we will go over them
one by one and later on I will also show
you how they work so the user interface
this is where your user interacts with
your bot this is where it will connect
with your chat bot for of course in
Google we like to think that if people
are looking for information a natural
way for them to go is Google so we are
investing a lot in our Google as systems
it's available on Google phones on our
Google home devices but also on
smartwatches in your car so that you can
be directly in touch with Google you can
also connect your own chat bot to
to do Google assistance so you could say
something like okay Google let me talk
to your to my chat BOTS and you will get
routed to the chat bot you've just built
of course we also know that not all
users are on Google all the time and
there are also a lot of platforms so we
also want to offer native integrations
with that so think about slack Facebook
Messenger
Cisco spark microsite putana are also
Amazon Alexa and third at least we also
want to have a software development kit
available the so that you can also
integrate in your mobile applications
your website so that you can have
complete flexibility on how your users
want to get in touch with your chat bot
the second building block is the
conversational agent platform and his
job is very simple but also very
complicated he has to understand humans
so he has to understand something like
can I get a pizza with bacon and cheese
make that a large one and oh at some
Aleph Center costs this very human way
in structured way that people
communicates so we as developers of
course we want to have a nice structure
JSON format where we can act upon and we
can do some nice applications upon but
that's unfortunately not the way most
people talk to us and that's where we
have to find this conversational agent
platform and this is exactly what API
dot AI does API today I was a company we
acquired less than one year ago and it's
one of the top use platforms of building
chat BOTS just a quick poll how many
people are familiar with the API dot AI
so I think that's a nice and it's around
30 to 40 percent of the room are already
aware of it and I think if I see this
question within one year
that would be even more especially if
you pay a lot of attention in my session
okay so we've covered the two building
blocks now to the fulfillment sites so
once we figured out what user actually
wants we also have to make it happen and
this happens in the fulfillment site
this is your backends this is where you
write your application like you're used
to do today but also they're on Google
cloud platform we have some very
interesting options to lock onto so the
first thing you can do is you can build
up your own virtual machines you can
build up your
Network you can set up your own firewall
and you can really build your
application from the ground up having
complete control over your configuration
and your control a next thing you can do
is you can move a little bit more to the
managed service to the more agile very
of working you can use containers where
the dependencies are adequate and
concluded and you can run it in a
managed version like Google container
engine so this is the containers as a
servers but of course you can also
abstract it a little bit more further
and only concentrate on the application
code then you use platform as a service
and this could be App Engine we have for
example snap at snapchat is using
snapchat snapchat is using App Engine to
be globally available for all the
customers across the world without
having to provision virtual machines
provision networks only concentrate on
their core application and the most
abstract thing we have right now is
actually a cloud function so you don't
focus on the application level but you
focus on the function level and from
there on you can sell how far you want
to go so the more you go to the right
the more no-ops you have the more go you
go to the to your left the more control
and configuration options you have
available the app engines on the cloud
function zone is what we call the server
Liz owned this doesn't mean that there
are no servers available they just
abstract it away for you and you don't
have to worry about them you can just
focus on the code the scaling will come
automatically so if you have one request
or one million requests you don't care
it just works
and also you only pay for what you use
so this makes it very easy to get
started with it to play with it and if
it's exercised you can just go with it
the same store we we had at the Philips
you in the keynote earlier today so when
we look at the cloud functions
specifically they are very perfect
positions for an event or get the event
oriented architecture this could be
background functions so for example if
you upload a file onto Google Cloud
storage
you can trigger a function and you can
for example get some metadata
use one of these nice machine-learning
api's to get some metadata about the
video or about a picture so that you can
launch it you can attach it to the
storage this is also available for
google cloud pub/sub and also with
firebase integrations the other thing
you can do is you can make an HTTP
function and then you can use it as a
web hook you can then start to easily
integrated and usually use it as sort of
a glue for order api's like for example
the g3 the AAP ice but also with API to
the eye and this is where of course the
perfect fit is happening so this is the
basic architecture is everyone clear
with the three building blocks awesome
so now I will go over them in and
demonstration I will try to build a
google web store from scratch so bear
with me we will go into this together
and we will see what we end up with the
things I will use is the API dot AI as a
conversational HR platform for the
fulfillment site we will use a cloud
function and then on the user interface
we will see how it interacts with slack
and how that works and hopefully under
10 minutes so let's get going okay
bear with me
so the thing you see right now is the
API dot AI interface on the left side
you have your configuration options and
on the right side you can directly test
it out and start interacting with the
chat bot you're building an API though
they either two very important concepts
to be aware of the first one is intense
the second ones are entities intense are
actions your people your users want to
execute and and entities are objects
your users want to act upon so in my
example I want to - Matt - to make this
Google web shop so I'm going to make a
product entity and I'm going to sell
hopefully some Google pixel phones and
you see they also have the option to add
synonyms because people use the same
word for different for the different
words for the same object so we'll also
add pixel I will also add the plural
Google pixels and pixels as well next
thing we want to sell maybe Google home
Google homes and people also call it
sometimes such as a home and a homes we
have a chromecast chromecast and last
but not least the Chromebook Chromebooks
and we've now created our own entities
the next thing we want to do is make it
first intent and you see they're already
too intense default in place so the
first one is the welcome intent this
will be launched when the user starts to
interact with your chatbot and the
second one is the fallback intent if API
DoDEA is not able to figure out the
intent
it's a fallback and it will guide the
user to the right direction by maybe
asking to repeat the sentence so let's
take a look at the Welcome intent and
you can say something like user says hi
or hello and then you can response and
you say something like hey welcome to
this awesome event what Google products
do you want we
it's and now we can normally directly
test this so we can say hi you see the
default welcome and 10 is launched and
the response is hi welcome to the
assassin awesome event what Google
products do you want so of course we
also want to make our own intense and if
you're running a web shot we're actually
hoping that people will buy some
something so we can take if we can make
an intent called buy product and the
user could say something like hey can I
buy five Chromebooks or maybe something
like can I get three chromecast's or
maybe something like can you give me
nine Google homes and what you see is
happening that API today is using
machine learning and natural language
processing to figure out which entities
are in place so it's figuring out ah
this Google home this Chromebook this
chromecast
this is actually the product entity we
just created next to that it's also
figuring out the number so we can give a
response as well say like sure and then
we can use parameters to refer to what
the user set so we can say like number
of products devices are on their way we
save it and we can directly start to
play with it so we say hey okay the
welcome intent is launched let's let's
try to buy something can i buy for
google pixels please
and what you see indeed it's figuring
out the by intent we just created it's
figuring out the parameters the number
and the product and it's launching the
correct answer we were hoping for so
let's make it a little bit more
interesting and maybe at the delivery
dates we call a date and what you see is
that API dot AI has a lot of entity
types already in place so you have dates
you have geographic locations you have
time zones all of these things and the
one I'm interested in right now it's a
date entity the next thing we can do is
we can make these parameters required
for the intent to be complete so we can
say a by intent is only complete if you
have the number of products the actual
product and also the delivery date so we
touch we make it required and then we
can also prompt the user if it doesn't
get enough information we can prompt
something like sure when do you want the
product devices to be delivered we can
add a response as well they will be
delivered on date of course we say if
what we're doing and let's try it again
can also something interesting just for
you to know so I trained the model with
Google homes chromecast Chromebooks and
in my example I was using the Google
pixel so it's obviously smart enough to
figure out okay I'm expecting an entity
there you don't have to give him an
effort thing this is the power of these
kind of entities I can also now just add
another entity and it will also take it
into account in all its training and
that's doing so let's write out scan I
buy three chromecast okay
so you see at first sight because I'm
just beginning to train this model that
was not already able to figure it out so
it was asking me what is the product and
now it's asking me when should it be
delivered and we can say something like
next week Monday and what you're seeing
here I think it's very cool is that the
system is able to figure out okay
the intent is by product the number and
the product are there and the date is an
exact date that we as developers love
you know and we as a user we just want
to say tomorrow or next week Monday we
want to act in a human way we don't want
to adjust to technology this is the
point what I was bringing earlier so
pretty cool or not okay another thing we
can do so now I showed you the the
conversational agent platform how this
works but we also want to have this
fulfillment site is back inside so if
people something actually buy something
you also want your ERP system to kick in
you want to really start something going
on in your backends so to show you that
I'm going to make another intent and the
way of linking intents is with another
important concept called contacts so if
people are buying something there is a
chance that you also want to do
something else so we can after that an
end-user has bought a product he is in
some cord of a flow and we cook all this
we could call this the buying mode what
we can do then as we can make another
intense we call it add an order and we
can here insert an input context also
buying mode so the system now knows that
if a like wants something as the user
has bought something there's a big
chance that he also will launch the add
another intent and the user could say
something like add another or another
one please oh I save it
and this time we're not going to put the
response into API dot AI but we're going
to use the web hook the fulfillment site
the third building block of my
presentation earlier on so the
fulfillment is configured over here it's
one web hook it's my project name in
Google cloud platform and it's a cloud
function called fulfillment I will now
show you how this one looks like in
Google cloud platform so basically it's
a very short function written in nodejs
it's getting JSON body from from API to
the I and it's going to look for the
action field and if the action field is
something like add another it will get
the quantity it will add one and it will
response something like here you go the
new number of devices are ordered you
set the HTTP header and you set the
status to 200 you sent a response back
and API oh yeah I can take it from there
so now I want to make sure that also the
action field so this is actually the
field where my cloud function is looking
at so this has to be there and then we
can normally try it out again let's go
to the whole flow okay welcome
can I buy maybe we can try can i order
five Google pixels sure when do you want
to Google pixel devices to believers
today of course I'm sure they're able to
be delivered and you see now again the
intent API today I was figuring out the
intent it was figuring out the the good
parameters by having a conversation with
me as the end user and it's also giving
now this context of buying mode so API
today is now aware from hey maybe this
add another thing is something that I
can expect now so now for the moment of
truth
my tree my list two of my building
blocks coming together so let's try to
add an order and here you go six devices
are ordered pretty cool now ah
I mean it's maybe maybe a little bit
stupid for this demonstration but if you
think about it and just I think less
than 10 minutes we were able to have a
fully scalable chat bot working of
course it's still only a
proof-of-concept but if you start
thinking about these kind of
applications and you can really build
this inside your companies to interact
with your end-users with your partners
but also with your employees for example
you can really already make a huge step
forward so a last thing I want to show
you is my final building block this was
the user interface so here we have all
the native the integrations available we
also have links to the software
development kit actions on Google I
believe that you will know that this
will be working so I want to show you
today slack we make sure it's turned on
and then we go to my API dot AI bots and
slack and we basically say hey oh let's
do the one thing in IT that always works
turning it off and on again of course
I can also blame it on slack of course
no no
ah welcome to this awesome event while
Google pros do you want huh
no we're talking this one is still not
completely well trained we can look into
this Chromebook ah okay that's uh ah no
I know I think I only said hello in the
training right so when I was using this
intent I was making this welcome intent
just for your information I only trained
it on saying hello and hi and I was
saying hi right okay I was saying hi
with a capital so this is where you have
to train the model will automatically
train so what you will do and also maybe
ing will touch upon this this is of
course machine learning so it learns
every time so you have to train it so
you can say like hi they should launch
it default welcome intents so you
approve that and then the the system is
learning and you're making your product
better and better so that's where it
takes a little bit time and that's where
it's a little bit tricky for me to
figure it out in ten minutes
but we will get there I want to buy
three Google homes today who actually
have the Google home at home okay
so the one thing like once you have one
you want to have one at in every room
because you start to get you used to
saying something like turn my lights on
and turn my lights off so that's why
another one is good intent you maybe
want to have and here you go four
devices are ordered
so there you go
I hope this was interesting for you as
you know it's always tricky to do with
them a life on stage but what I've did I
went over these building blocks I
started with the conversational agent
platform showing you how you can input
human instructed human data and
transform it into JSON and act upon with
a cloud function and we did the native
integration and in slack so there was
only a very short proof of concept I
hope you can start to play with it and
show it to your bosses and show you them
how cool of this but if you want to do
the real work it's interesting to listen
to 10 Danielle's from ING and they will
share their lessons work Thank You
mikheil and hello everybody my name is
Tim and indeed I'm working in a small
but enthusiastic team at ING and we are
actively building a chatbot for banking
and what I especially liked about the
talk of Micheel was that it brought back
the initial excitement we felt when we
started to use a pillow di now we are a
couple of months later and we still like
it but it has evolved so it's a kind of
journey and I will take you along in the
next 15 minutes along this journey but
first I would like to spend a few
minutes on why this is of importance to
ing this type of technology so as we are
in ing s hometown I suppose that most of
you know that ing is a global and
universal bank and there has been a
tremendous focus on customer experience
the last few years and also on let's say
fostering internally a real engineering
culture and the reason being that
bankers need to be where their clients
are and more and more our customers are
on social platforms are on all the
digital ecosystems so it's a very very
natural thing for ing to explore the
possibilities of chatbots
and so here she is she's called Marie
and she
is what we call your digital assistant
and it's about six months ago that we
fired up a bit of the eye for the very
first time and now six months six months
later Marie is in production for a well
controlled group of customers and ing
employees and as she will get better and
better
because you need users to train her
there so we trained her thanks to the
input we get from the first users we
will gradually increase the group of
people that have access to Mary
hopefully until everyone every customer
of ing can use her secondly what can she
do she can help customers with questions
and requests about cards don't be
mistaken it's not she's not a
question-and-answer bot but she is what
we would like to call a do bot she does
things for customers like ordering a
replacement cards activating a card for
usage abroad resetting a pin code which
sometimes happen after a night out as
our people in the contact center know to
tell me initially we have spent quite
some time on deciding what the exact
scope of Marie should be and now every
day we are happy we did so because
having a clear scope for your BOTS saves
you a lot of energy along the way energy
you will need to cover all the other
aspects that come with building a decent
chat bot maybe a last word on why cards
first of all cards it's about what you
can do with this tangible piece of
plastic so in the people's head there is
a kind of natural boundary it's clear
for people when you talk about bank
cards what you're actually talking about
and secondly and she is still getting a
lot of calls on from people who want
help with their cards like resetting
this pin code and so on and so forth why
we have chosen for facebook messenger as
user interface well simply because it is
popular as you have seen with me he'll
is very easy to deploy other
channels as well now before I do the
demo which I hope will work and then we
will after the demo we will also peek I
will open up abital to the AI so that we
can peek into the brain of Marie
together and then you see thus a more
extended bot than the one of Michiel but
before I do so I would like to introduce
briefly the overall architecture of
Marie to you and what you see is that
for the user interface that was simple
that is just one component it's Facebook
Messenger but the conversational agent
platform that we have split over two
components on the one hand a P dot ai
where we do all natural language
processing and that is important for us
because we want business people to
change what Matt is saying and therefore
we want to have all natural language
generation all the responses of Marie
also in one place and there is a second
component which is straight in the
middle and therefore we called it the
middleman and in that component we have
put some very specific logic for us
for example we are at the bank if a
customer orders a replacement card we
need to make sure that we authenticate
the customer and because the middleman
is in between facebook messenger epitaph
ai it knows at which point in the
conversation to stash the authentication
flow authentication which we do via a
one-time password which we send out via
Twilio then on the mobile phone the
customer types it in gives it to Mary
and the person is authenticated as you
can see we are fully in the clouds so
everything below this thick orange line
are all the back-end systems of ing at
30 years of IT history piled up in the
cellar and above is all clouds now we
did in the cloud and that is one of the
reasons that allowed us to do it in six
months now don't be mistaken at the bank
security confidentiality
we are it's all important so we work
very hard with our security officers
information and operational risk
managers our fraud experts to make it as
secure as it needs to be so we are glad
that we did that with them and it worked
out fine
there are three other components on the
screen which is the sentiment analysis
API of Google because we're keeping
track of the sentiment of an
conversation because if the conversation
gets too bad we want people in the
contact center to step in therefore we
have the sentiment and intervention
dashboard and then last but not least
Marie is talking English today and we
are looking into ways to make her
quickly let's say a polyglot because in
Belgium you need at least three
languages for even so we are doing some
experiments over there okay now I hope
because this is the corporate laptop and
there is a demo with real back-end
interaction I hope it is going to work
out fine so can I have the laptop on the
screen okay so you see here she is the
advantage of about is that she is not
nervous like I am but luckily she still
remembers me hi Tim she says which is
important for the personalization and
for the moment only English okay now I
will tell it immediately I want to use
my cart abroad which was one of the use
cases I told you about and if anything
is that within a minute I will need this
one time pass first and I had put my
phone away because I did not want to be
distracted but I have to be distracted
okay at first we wanted to use only text
but quickly we learned that once your
customer is in a dialogue please keep
him there and then visual elements like
you see here it's called quick replies
it helps a lot now a debit card is a
more interesting case because there it
depends on the destination if regard
needs to be activated as well as you see
as you see as well Marie her responses
are not less a flat head there's a bit
of joy there's a slight fan element
which is the personality of about
something you need to think about now
I'm travelling to Peru and she will ask
me if she needs to activate my cart and
I will tell her yes that she needs to do
so and she has sent me now pin codes to
react insist II
yes yeah those are small things we still
need to fix sometimes let's say that the
conversations are not all yet up to
standards aha
and now comes an important element and
which is nice in for example facebook
Messenger this is a carousel instead of
asking the customer which card or
whether the last digits and on and so on
we show the cards a person has and then
it becomes much easier to do to choose
one now I'm a bit i had to enlarge the
screen a bit so I'm missing here because
there should be extra cards available a
valid a valid there they are and so what
we do as you can see most of the
information on the card has been masked
this is for security reasons also in the
text below you will see that we have
applied masking because we do not want
Facebook to know the numbers of the
cards of our customers okay they know
that they will have cards but that's not
much information so I'm simply going to
tell Murray this one and then like me
he'll already set this is quite
wonderful of course dashes slashes you
don't need to worry about it
natural language we'll just make sure
that you get where you need to be
voila and now Murray will send she's now
informing the people at the backend that
they need to do some things she has sent
confirmation mail and that's about it
okay now let's have a look into her
brain and at this point in time we have
about 150 intense so be prepared when
you're going to build a real bot be
prepared to have a lot of intense we
have about ten full-fledged use cases I
think half of the intern
for that and then there's a lot of stuff
like small talk what are you wearing
what where are you living or what are
you things people ask and you better
have an answer to that otherwise they
think Marie is boring which is not now
to keep structure the dialogues we have
are all multi intent and I will go
quickly to the use of broad one with it
so you see that we are applying a naming
convention the name of the use case is
coming back and we are keeping track of
where we are in the conversation and to
to make that work you really need to get
your context right so interns and
entities are very important but you will
get nowhere in a more advanced but
without contexts so we are setting two
contexts one for the overall use case
and a second one to make sure that the
answer to the question Marie is asking
at that point in time that that answer
is captured correctly so she is asking
for the car type so the outgoing context
is then how it's about car types and
then we have the intent if it's a credit
card then you see this context coming
back as an input context context very
important and keeping also an eye on the
time so multi intent dialogues glue
together by context which means that the
the dialogue logic is fully driven
within a patate I also know coding there
it's all configuration which we like now
I will because time is limited and I
will not touch upon a cloud functions
this is a very rich topic and we are
around to talk about it but it's better
not to talk about it then to talk to
shortly about it now I will demonstrate
the last part which is our conversation
that worked
therefore I will get quite impolite so I
will say this bot is terrible
which I sometimes but seldomly think and
normally she is a bit set haha something
although something in Fela okay so now
someone in our contact center has been
notified that a conversation is d
railing and fir as it is very important
that people even if the conversation
the automatic conversation does not work
out that they leave Murray with a good
feeling so we can step into the
conversation which is the second major
role of Arsenal authentication of this
middleman so I'm now you see here to
complete trace of the conversation the
like facebook messenger this stays
available for a long time
and I can turn off Murray here and I can
hide him from the contact center voila
Poppa and normally follow so I human
take over this is very very important so
if I thank you
so if you ask me at the last six months
you have you had a lot of fun developing
this but what are your main takeaways
and I would say one make sure that you
have a clear scope and defend that
against the many stakeholders you will
get along your path to make sure you
master the concept of contexts it's
non-trivial but it's very powerful and
it will allow you to make multi intent
dialogues then as a third element think
about the personality of your boat make
it explicit we worked with marketing for
that and I grew up on it and then the
fourth element is make sure that you're
both talks as quickly as possible to
other people than those who are building
the bots because each time we did it we
were amazed by the creativity of people
to say or to ask for simple things in a
thousand different ways so you hand over
the bolts then you see people going wild
and then you think oh I never thought of
that at rinses and so on and so forth so
you need about 30 to 50 utterances for
the entry intensive which is the number
we are striving for that was number four
and number five is never leave your boat
alone and with this concluding words I
would like to hand the world over again
to me heal for the wrapper
[Applause]
so thank you very much them very cool
and interesting to see what you are
building here just to wrap it up we have
discussed some building blocks first we
were talking about this user interface
and there we set the importance of being
cross-platform availability so you have
this native integrations as well as this
as as the case to integrate with API
today I very powerful and on the
fulfillment side you have a lot of
options on the platform as well
interesting to note as well as that API
data is for free right now the native
integrations as well and for for example
the cloud functions the first 1 million
calls or something are for free so it is
really easy to get going you don't need
budget approvals or something like that
and then when it works out like in the
case of Tim you can own easily scale
with demands one last thing I want to
give you before we wrap this off is that
we've covered a lot of technical talks
here a demonstration and technical
insights but when you're dealing with
humans like the marketing and how you
deal with people becomes very important
as well while developing or Google
assistance we have learned lessons along
the way and we're also sharing this with
the community so also put some
considerable amount of effort in this
interaction with humans so basically
that's it I hope it was a very
interesting session we did the basic run
through and then the expert experience
of someone running it into production so
I want to thank Tim again I want to
thank you for your attention and your
energy and I hope you have a very nice
rest of the day thank you
[Music]
you